>> Sean: ALL RIGHT.
FOX BUSINESS PRIME IS BACK WITH
NEW SHOWS LIKE "AMERICAN BUILT",
"AMERICAN DYNASTY" AND "HOW
AMERICA WORKS" HOSTED BY MIKE
ROWE.
JUST LIKE LAST SEASON, HE'S
GOING TO BE TAKING YOU BEHIND
THE SCENES FOR AN IN DEPTH LOOK
AT THE PEOPLE THAT KEEP THIS
COUNTRY RUNNING, THE PEOPLE THAT
MAKE THE COUNTRY GREAT.
HERE'S A SNEAK PEEK OF THE FIRST
EPISODE OF THE NEW SEASON, WHICH
FOCUSES ON THE MEN AND WOMEN
THAT KEEP AMERICA'S CARGO
MOVING.
THINK ABOUT LIFE WITHOUT THEM.
NOT PRETTY.
>> INSTEAD OF ME BEING DOWN HERE
PICKING UP LITTLE BY LITTLE,
HALF BUCKETS OR QUARTER BUDGETS,
HE ROLLS IT DOWN HERE IN THE BIG
PILES WHERE I CAN GET FULL
BUCKETS EACH TIME.
SAVES US TIME IN THE END.
EVERYTHING IS GOING GOOD RIGHT
NOW.
GOING SMOOTH.
>> AS JOHNNY IS ABOUT TO FIND
OUT -- HIS TROUBLES WITH THE
HOPPER ARE NOT OVER YET.
>> GO AHEAD.
>> THE CHUTE IS NOT OPEN.
>> YOU'RE KIDDING, RIGHT?
>> Sean: HERE WITH MORE, OUR
FRIEND AND THE HOST OF "HOW
AMERICA WORKS" AIRING MONDAY
NIGHT ON OUR SISTER NETWORK, THE
FOX BUSINESS NETWORK.
MIKE ROWE IS WITH US.
GOING BACK TO YOUR DAYS OF -- I
LOVE HOW YOU -- HE DOESN'T HAVE
TO TALK.
VERY COOL.
I TOLD YOU, YOU HAVE THE ONLY
OTHER JOB I WOULD WANT IN TV
WITH THE TWO SHOWS THAT YOU
HAVE, NOW THE THIRD SHOW YOU
HAVE WITH US WITH FOX BUSINESS.
THAT IS "DIRTY JOBS" AND
"DEADLIEST CATCH."
I LOVE ALL OF IT.
I DON'T THINK AMERICANS TRULY
APPRECIATE WHAT IT TAKES TO GET
THE BIG CRAB LEGS THAT AMERICANS
LIKE TO EAT.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT IT TAKES TO
MANUFACTURE SOMETHING.
I DON'T THINK THEY FULLY
UNDERSTAND THE IMPACT OF WHAT
FARMERS DO FOR US EVERY DAY AND
RANCHERS DO FOR US EVERY DAY AND
IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE, YOU
KNOW, GETTING EVERYTHING PACKED
AND MOVED AND OFF OF SHIPS AND
OUT TO STORES.
I DON'T THINK WE REALLY REALIZE.
YOU THINK AMERICANS APPRECIATE
IT?
>> WELL, TWO DIFFERENT THINGS.
REALIZATION AND APPRECIATION.
MOST OF US HAVE NEVER REALLY
REALIZED IT.
BUT WE'VE ALWAYS INTUITIVELY
APPRECIATED IT.
WE KNOW THAT WHEN WE FLICK THE
SWITCH AND THE LIGHT COMES ON,
THAT IS THE RESULT OF A MIRACLE.
THAT MIRACLE IS MADE POSSIBLE BY
MEN AND WOMEN DOING THINGS OUT
OF SIGHT AND OUT OF MIND.
WHAT I WORRY ABOUT IS THE
OVERALL LACK OF APPRECIATION
THAT HAS INFECTED IN MY VIEW OUR
SOCIETY OVER THE LAST 30 OR 40
YEARS.
MY TV SHOWS, THE TWO THAT YOU
MENTIONED ARE JUST AN ATTEMPT TO
TAP THE COUNTRY ON THE SHOULDER
AND SAY HEY, LOOK, IF WE DON'T
HANG ON TO THIS FUNDAMENTAL
APPRECIATION FOR THE KINDS OF
JOBS THAT MAKE CIVILIZED LIFE
POSSIBLE FOR THE REST OF US,
WE'LL HAVE A LIST OF UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES LONGER THAN YOUR
ARM.
>> Sean: DID COVID CHANGE THAT?
GET A GREATER APPRECIATION FOR
PEOPLE THAT WORK IN THE MEDICAL
FIELD?
EVERYBODY FROM DOCTORS AND
NURSES AND ORDERLIES AND
EVERYBODY IN BETWEEN?
DID WE GET A GREATER
APPRECIATION FOR TRUCK DRIVERS,
IF THEY WEREN'T TRUCKING AND
PACKERS WEREN'T PACKING AND
FARMERS NOT FARMING, WE WOULDN'T
HAVE SURVIVED.
YOU THINK PEOPLE HAVE AN
INCREASED APPRECIATION?
>> I HATE TO PAINT WITH TWO
BROAD A BRUSH, I KNOW I DO.
I KNOW THAT THE WHOLE ZOOM
WORLD, THE CONVERSATION WE'RE
HAVING RIGHT NOW, THREE YEARS
AGO, THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN.
I CAME TO NEW YORK.
I SAT IN THE STUDIO WITH YOU.
THIS IS MADE POSSIBLE BY FIBER
OPTICS AND MEN DRIVING AROUND IN
ALL HOURS MAKING SURE THAT
EVERYTHING IS CONNECTED.
SO I THINK IN A LOT OF WAYS,
COVID GAVE US A WAKE-UP CALL.
I'M AFRAID IT DID SOMETHING ELSE
TOO, SEAN.
I'M A BROKEN RECORD ON THIS.
I WAS LISTENING TO JOE CONCHA A
COUPLE SEGMENTS BACK.
GO DOWN THE LIST OF THINGS THAT
ARE IMPORTANT TO VOTERS.
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT NOBODY IS
TALKING ABOUT.
NOBODY IS TALKING ABOUT THE
SEVEN MILLION ABLE-BODIED MEN
THAT ARE NOT ONLY UNEMPLOYED
TODAY BUT THEY HAVE
AFFIRMATIVELY LEFT THE WORK
FORCE.
I SPENT 1 1/2 HOURS INTERVIEWING
A BRILLIANT ECONOMIST THAT
BELIEVES THAT THAT STATISTIC FAR
MORE SO THAN UNEMPLOYMENT
NUMBERS AND ANY OTHER METRIC IS
THE THING THAT SHOULD SCARE THE
HELL OUT OF US.
THAT NUMBER OF ABLE-BODIED MEN
COMBINED WITH THE 11 MILLION
JOBS THAT ARE OPEN, THAT HAS
NEVER HAPPENED IN OUR COUNTRY
BEFORE.
IF WE DON'T FIX THAT, WE'RE ON
THAT PART OF THE MAP WHERE IT
SAYS HERE BY DRAGONS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT IS COMING
NEXT.
>> Sean: MIKE ROWE, LOVE HAVING
YOU.
LOVE ALL OF YOUR SHOWS.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US.
TUNE IN TO MIKE ROWE